apelaciones al alma de la nación a dos
meses de las elecciones de mitad de
mandato
mientras estoy aquí esta noche la
igualdad y la democracia están siendo
atacadas no nos hacemos ningún favor si
fingimos lo contrario
el presidente de eeuu joe biden ofreció
un discurso a la nación en horario de
máxima audiencia desde el independence
hall de filadelfia para rechazar las
acciones de los republicanos alineados
con donald trump que según él amenazan
los cimientos del país
oímos cada vez más hablar de violencia
como una herramienta política aceptable
en este país no lo es nunca puede serlo
así que quiero decir esto simple y
llanamente no hay lugar para la
violencia política en eeuu
según una encuesta publicada en el medio
británico the economist el 40% de los
estadounidenses ve probable una guerra
civil en la próxima década ante datos
como ese y más de un año después de la
toma del capitolio el mandatario cargó
duramente contra lo que llamó el
extremismo republicano de los seguidores
del movimiento maga américa where the
game que según él son promotores de la
persecución contra derechos y libertades
como el aborto las fuerzas de maga están
decididas a hacer retroceder a este país
retroceder a una nación donde no hay
derecho a elegir ni derecho a la
privacidad ni derecho a la
anticoncepción o el derecho a casarse
con quien amas promueven líderes
autoritarios y avivó en las llamas de la
violencia política que son una amenaza a
nuestros derechos personales en todo
caso la figura del magnate sigue siendo
protagónica en el escenario político aún
pese al reciente allanamiento del fbi a
su residencia vacacional en florida en
busca de documentación clasificada
extraída ilegalmente de la casa blanca
la realidad en estas dos campañas y en
las de todo el país en ambos extremos es
que donald trump es el momento social es
el momento político es la presencia
dominante la cuenta atrás para las
elecciones se acerca y los demócratas
aspiran a conservar el legislativo
mientras que el ala republicana estaría
allanando el camino para las próximas
presidenciales